this our Marks & Spencer has confirmed
950 jobs are at risk as part of plans to
reduce stall management and head office
rolls skies in King joins me now and lot
of people wondering really whether MLS
is going to survive well I don't think
that's necessarily in doubt Adam because
whilst it's been fairly well documented
that it has a clothing and home division
which is under a bit of pressure it
still has a very very successful and
highly profitable food business so I
don't think that is necessarily going to
be an issue now the background to this I
should mention is that you've just
eluded Adam M&S was a business that was
already in difficulties prior to the
outbreak of kovat 19 in the last
financial year truly a pre-tax profits
fell from five hundred and eleven
million pounds so four hundred and three
million pounds which was the lowest
result sir Lowe's profits from M&S for
three decades and now they published
these results on May the 20th when the
UK was really only going into the the
lockdown you could say and at the time
it announced what it called and never
the same again program which was
basically its argument its analysis if
you like that the shopping market the
retail market in the UK had been
completely changed forever and ever that
the acceleration to digital was going to
be a lot quicker than previously
anticipated and that people would be
moving away from stores more rapidly
than anticipated as well now they'd
already announced as part of that plans
to close between 100 and 120 high street
stores they were already got to about
fifty four of that so far and I think
this is the next leg of this as you say
the jobs are largely going to be in head
office some store management roles as
well they're looking for volunteers for
redundancies but really Adam this echoes
what we've seen elsewhere on the high
street John Lewis Partnership announcing
redundancies recently boots big job
losses there you are seeing this right
across the retail sector as the move to
digital accelerates and people move away
from traditional bricks-and-mortar
type physical retail can read you a bit
from the statements here since the
proposed changes would affect nine
hundred and fifty rolls across central
support functions in field and central
operations and properly install
management M&S
started collective consultation with its
employee representatives group and a set
our intention to first off voluntary
redundancy to affected colleagues I
should also say that during the lockdown
M&S had some 7,000 store colleagues on
furlough those were largely in the
clothing and home division because it's
simply food outlets by and large stayed
open throughout the crisis